[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp la seule
émission où l'on parle alimentation
agriculture écologie est un peu
politique et cette semaine nous recevons
yves marie le bourdonnec c'est lui qui
va passer sur le grill est avec moi pour
présenter cette émission jean pierre
montanay bonjour jean pierre bonjour
brigitte beaux jours yves marie le
bourdonnec bonjour jean pierre bonjour j
bonjour yves marie le bourdonnec vous
est surnommé le boucher des stars et la
star des bouchers tout le monde
s'arrache votre viande et se pressent
dans votre bouche ridan hier le couteau
d'argent où l'on peut y croiser entre
autres yannick alléno ou encore alain
ducasse vous jouissez d'une renommée
internationale en ayant inspiré le
personnage principal du roman de joyce
sûrement comme une bête le new york
times vous a également décerné le titre
de producteur du meilleurs hamburgers du
monde en france vous êtes sacré meilleur
boucher de paris et vous avez créé un
mouvement iluv bidoche en 2011 vous êtes
prêt à tout pour défendre la bonne
viande jusqu'à poser nue dans un
calendrier de 2012 version personnalisée
des dieux du stade vous pousser aussi
des coups de gueule pour dénoncer les
dérives de l'agriculture dans un livre
l'effet boeuf un lien de la ferme à la
fourchette que l'on retrouve jusque dans
le menu du jour jean pierre et oui
j'allais dire de l'état blue fourneaux
au menu
drôle de steak un stack au point et en
dessert un classique de la pâtisserie le
paris brest dans le 2 se déplacent c'est
écrit dessus c'est comme le port salut
l'étiquetage de toutes les viandes
devient désormais obligatoire pour vos
poules est logé à la même enseigne que
dans les pieds dans le plat une enquête
norvégienne qui décoiffe si on mange
sainement on peut gagner jusqu'à 10 ans
d'espérance de vie ça vous intéresse eh
bien on vous dira quelles sont ces
aliments au miracle allez on passe à
table tout de suite cuisine et
confidences
[Musique]
alors brigitte disons-le à notre invité
a réussi un exploit à réconcilier comme
vous l'avez dit deux mots qui semblait
assez antinomique comme sa bouche et
estar footballeur et star oui ça sonne
bien mais boucher et stars et bien
pourtant parlant de l'entrecôte comme
people picasso parle de la peinture ou
lagerfeld de la haute couture eh bien il
a réussi à rendre sexy et glamour
l'onglet et la basse côte alors vous
imaginez bien qu'il n'allait pas
débarquer ici en vantant les mérites du
brocoli lui qui fournit en tourner dos
mick jagger en personne yves marie a le
sens de la com donc pas question de nous
proposer un simple steaks pour aller
aller retour non voilà qui nous a
préparé une de ses recettes fétiches le
steak au foin appellation suffisamment
ambigu pour entretenir le mystère et
pour l'anecdote brigitte faire du foin
c'est l'ancien expression pour dire
faire du buzz donc on a hâte de savoir
ce que l'icône des bio va nous faire
déguster un steak mélangé avec du foie
ou alors un steak cuit et fumer dans le
foin réponse du mari c'est plus complexe
que ça aurait été trop facile non pour
véhiculer le le parfum du foie j'utilise
le gras en fait j'utilise ingrat qui
s'appelle grappa 9 qui est le gras des
poignées d'amour de la fin que je fais
mature et très longtemps on a dégradé
grèce de panneaux chez nous dans nos
frigos qui ont plus de deux ans de
d'affinage et on les fait fumer avec du
foin et donc on vient apporter ce goût
de miel ce goût fumé deux ans ça reste
comme ça leurs soins et le gras le long
de l'opération de fumage se fait au
début et ensuite on laisse ces éternels
le gras et éternelle il peut rester très
très longtemps et ça veut dire quoi
concrètement fumée du gras et fumé du
gras ça veut dire mettre le gras dans un
fumoir et mettre le du fonds à la place
du de copeaux de être pour bien fumé le
donc on a fait brûler on le fait brûler
ce fait légèrement brûlé accord donc
c'est un filmage à froid quand sako et
après vous donc avec ce gras vous le
mettez autour de la viande comme on peut
la cdc la bardot qui
ont choisi un morceau de boeuf plutôt
cylindrique alors ça peut être du filet
ça peut être une basse côte ça peut être
ce qu'on appelle nous le creux des reins
qui est un morceau du dos de l'animal et
on l'en tour de ce gr et ensuite on fait
des petits pavés on le fait grillé à la
plancha ou ou à la poêle avec du beurre
et moi j'ai conseillé de le faux de le
servir avec des pommes de terre fumée au
point voilà est donc là il ya
effectivement du foin
sous les pommes de terre et on sent
d'ailleurs un l'odeur de fumée on va le
goûter pour voir alors que moi ça
ressemble à quoi il faut le changer je
vous recommande de voter le gr g ca tout
doucement ce qu'est la ficelle n'est pas
que dans la ficelle mais on ne mange pas
le cas sissi est vrai pouvoir le manger
le maître en accompagnement avec vos
pommes de terre à côté d'accord et puis
vous pouvez attaquer le steak
directement alors lui le stack il a pavé
la pas été mis au point ni lors de nancy
ont été mature est d'accord alors c'est
combien de temps as l'air de pour ses
morceaux là on va jusqu'à 60 jours de
maturation donc vous avez déjà un bon
petit goût
alors le fois on sent bien gras oui ça
c'est bon c'est très bien je voulais en
fait je voulais retrouver je veux je
voulais mettre un lien entre l'herbe et
le goût de la viande je veux que mes
vaches ont le goût de et le goût de leur
terroir mais c'est pas dû fumer comme
sur une société a un goût assez
particulier quand même c'est plus miel
vous avez vu c'est plus miel c'est pas
oui c'est pas fumer comme on peut
l'entendre d'une poitrine de cochon
fumer ou de jambon fumé c'est donc cette
idée vous est venue de la ferme de l'air
de vouloir la la la de la transmettre à
charge un lien de continuité je
cherchais à trouver le lien qu'elle est
qu'elle est donné c'est important de
faire un lien entre l'animal et le
terroir entre la nourriture et le
terroir c'est ce qui est ce que pour
vous le plus important c'est là où vous
allez vous fournir celui-ci sont les
basques est très important pour moi
c'est que l'éleveur soit capable de
donner un peu de son paysage dans le
dans sa viande qu'on puisse raconter ça
à nos clients qu'on puisse faire rêver
nos clients avec ce produit comment vous
les choisissez vos éleveurs
aujourd'hui ils viennent à moi j'ai
beaucoup de chance mais je les choisis
pour fonction de quels critères comment
vous savez en phase 2 de ce que mangent
l'animal est ce qu'il vit d argent c
c'est en fonction généralement de son
savoir-faire de de son amour de ces
animaux de de la qualité de son produit
de sa de sa capacité à se remettre en
cause aussi parce que quelquefois il
faut complètement se remettre en cause
comme par exemple dans le monde bovin
quand je vais voir un éleveur très
souvent chaud j'ai dû dire on repart
d'une page blanche en europe on
recommence à zéro pourquoi un crocodile
qu'est ce qui vous a souvent j'arrive
dans des élevages où ces pubs où je ne
peux pas utilisé l'animal qui est déjà
qui est déjà mis en élevage parce qu'il
souvent il est émis pour d'autres
raisons en france le bovin est rarement
une élevé pour faire de la viande il est
d'abord élevée pour faire du lait ou
produire du veau et par défaut il est à
la viande ans il vient à la viande
ensuite donc on a on n'a pas la proche
première de denfert de la viande alors
que moi je veux que mon éleveurs et la
proche première d'en faire de la viande
je reviens au point brigitte c'est vous
qui avez inventé le foin dans la cuisine
où ça existe déjà parce que ça existait
déjà vous avez vous allez profiter vous
avait surfé sur cette entendu parler du
jambon au foin cet accord on cuit au
froid annoncée bien avant moi alors
trois choses à savoir sur le foin en
cuisine jean-pierre exactement brigitte
ça vous intéresse de cuisiner au point
ces herbes de pâturage je séchais sont
destinés au bétail à l'origine eh bien
figurez vous que c'est à la mode pour la
cuisine depuis que des glaneurs c'est à
dire des gens qui glane qui vont
ramasser de l'herbe dans les pâturages
ramasse ses airs de prairies pour en
faire des points qu'on appelle culinaire
parce que oui souvent les arts sont un
peu traités sont choisis sont
sélectionnés qui rassemble une flore
variées et abondante en altitude on aura
par exemple dans ce foin de l'a6
trinquet de fous nous des alpes de
l'abysse torte de l'oseille de la pensée
sauvage du plantain du cerfeuil la
cardamine des donc je connais pas bien
mais que vous connaissez sans doute et
le foin de crau par exemple c'est un
autre exemple de foin et bien il possède
même une aoc il accompagne parfaitement
la cuisson des viandes en cocotte j'ai
aussi compris qu'on pouvait mettre du
foie dans une cocotte poser un poulet
oui faire cuire comme ça à faire cuire
avec torréfié un peu le font avant le
taux refi à 1 vous le faites je tories
fier dans une cocotte sèche et puis
après vous rajouter vos ingrédients le
bouillon et tout ça ça va ça infuser et
ça va donner sur ce bout il faut pas
croire ça passe ça donne pas les goûts
forme dégoûterait doux au contraire très
exactement alors ça peut être des
volailles brigitte des agneaux qui suit
sur ce lit de foin et bien vont être
délicatement aromatisées et fumer leur
chair on peut aussi fumer au point des
légumes ou des pommes de terre et même
des fromages alors il faut - il faut pas
les faire cuire trop longtemps autre
technique on peut aussi faire infuser du
foie dans une sauce ou dans une crème ce
qu'ils valent à parfumer pour des
desserts même avec une crème anglaise au
foin sachez qu'il existe aussi des
produits dérivés comme des sirops de
fois que l'on peut incorporer dans une
recette ou boire avec un peu d'eau vive
le foin ou contourner ou pour votre 4
points je alors c'est je le trouve dans
le gers j'ai une petite agricultrice qui
manquent iman fournit donc du foin
gastronomique c'est la gastronomie c'est
un flingue à ce qu'on veut dire quoi
qu'il ait
d'abord les voitures et les fermes il
n'est pas vraiment le ca y est les
prairies sont jamais traités on traite
pas les prairies donc c'est plutôt
naturel mais ce qui est important c'est
qu'ils soient sans poussière sans sans
résidu d'autres choses il faut qu'il
soit consommé qu'il est il avait les
prix mais naturellement non il est lavé
îles et les lavez séchez
comme il faut pour qu'il soit c'est un
événement à la sorte et culinaire
français despinasse à votre passion vous
est l'aîné de croix dans la ferme de
votre enfance est ce que c est ce que
c'est le cas est ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter ce qu'il y avait dans cette
ferme là qui est ce qu'elle appartenait
à vous à vos parents j'ai été élevée moi
par mon oncle et ma tante en bretagne
dans un village qui s'appelle plus gai
l'accord entre perros guirec et paimpol
pour c'est pour vous situer et j'ai été
confiée à mon oncle et ma tante avec ma
soeur et nous sommes arrivés nous
arrivions de région parisienne ce que je
suis né à montreuil
j'avais 6 ans quand je suis arrivé chez
eux et je suis arrivé dans un monde
merveilleux au bord de la mer avec des
animaux jeu ça prend un fameux big je
voyais des animaux des vaches des
cochons des chèvres et j'étais fasciné
par par ces animaux j'adorais ces
animaux et mon oncle qui était un homme
très sage
motorisés à élever des animaux mais
m'expliquer toujours que l'animal
servait à quelque chose soit à nous
aider dans nos tâches pour un cheval ou
pour un chien ou alors à nous nourrir
soit par sont pas reçus par le lait soit
par par sa viande donc j'ai jamais eu de
problèmes psychologiques à manger les
animaux que j'adorais voilà ça parce
qu'après vous vous êtes vous devenu
bouche et donc vous avez développé ces
animaux comment on fait nos messages
pressant pour que ma tâche quand même
accès et comment on devient boucher dit
et il y avait un personnage qui venait
deux fois par an à la ferme pour abattre
l'animal que nous allions nous manger
parce que mon oncle et ma tante
produisait des veaux des vaches des
cochons et il les revendait et maze il
avait il faisait à battre un bovin une
fois par an avoue une fois par an et un
cochon une fois par an et se boucher
venait s'appelait monsieur kabel c'était
un monsieur que je que j'adorais que je
détestais puisqu'il était possible
qu'ils puissent un jour abattre un de
mes mots que j'ai lu que j'ai chéri
v et cet homme qui était très
particulier pour moi qui ai un petit peu
brut de décoffrage
quand je le voyais travailler j'étais
fasciné gtm est subjuguée par me
trouvais qu'il était très beau dans ses
gestes
j'étais vraiment je regardais ça avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'admiration ce jour
là je n'allais pas à l'école je le reste
est le regarder travailler et j'étais je
restais j'avais 7 8 9 ans à cette époque
là et la bête souffrait non du tout non
bah non c'est un animal qui a souffert
on ne peut pas le manger c'est c'est pas
plus il ya trop de stress est trop de
stress non il faut faire ça avec
beaucoup d'arrêts le faire avec beaucoup
de respect et lui le faisais le faisait
très très bien et est donc à table un
jour dans un dans un déjeuner deux
cousins on demande aux enfants qu'est ce
que vous ferez quand vous serez grand
quand mes cousins me disait pompiers ou
azou cosmologie nerfs
moi je disais moi je veux faire le
métier de monsieur kamel je ne savais
pas donner un nom à sa oui oui parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas vraiment bougé pour
vous un boucher c'est celui qui vendait
de la viande voilà je sais pas je ne
savais pas vraiment comment dès lors je
veux faire le messie le métier de
monsieur kabel et et c'est comme ça que
hélas ma tante était éberlué de
m'entendre dire ça moi qui était un
petit garçon très sensible qui
pleurnichait dès qu'on faisait du mal à
ces animaux mais comment tu vois et je
ne savais pas que j'avais pas les
arguments les mots pour lui expliquer
que ces gestes me fasciner et que je
n'appelle s'alarme m de là des comptes
lors de la 20e c'est un travail
d'artiste pour vous moi je revendique wa
van dyck être en quelque sorte un
artiste dont est ce que le geste il est
très précis ça prend parce que je crois
que vous vous formez aussi beaucoup de
gêne au bruit oui je forme beaucoup je
je je suis très
jeu suit très attentifs à ça à former
les équipes formées et puis faire aimer
mon métier c'est important les gestes et
puis aussi des outils des couteaux sont
différents selon qu'on s'attaque à telle
ou telle partie de l'animal j'ai marié
deux écoles vous savez il ya deux
grandes écoles enseigné dans l'art de la
découpe un oui dans le monde il ya l'art
il ya la découpe française et la découpe
japonaise et on s'oppose tous les
différends centrale est la grande
différence entre les deux c'est que le
lait que la découpe française est une
des coupes très chirurgicale ça qu'on
doit connaître l'ensemble des muscles ne
jamais les sectionné faire très
attention quand on les prélève alors que
le japonais est une des coupes
géométriques purement géométriques c'est
à dire qu'il tranche tout le temps dans
le contre fibre parce que les japonais
consomment la viande tout le temps cru
août cuite ou juste snacks et alors que
nous on la consomme beaucoup en plat en
plats mijotés finalement le steak en
france c'est quelque chose de très très
récent ça date d'une centaine d'années
sa date du début de 20e avant de manger
que des viandes en sauce c'est marrant
ces deux pays deux couteaux de fabrique
donc voilà voilà déjà et c'est aussi
deux pays quand une approche compliquée
du bovin
avoir un bovin au japon c'est compliqué
il ya pas de prairies ça c'est une île
avec une montagne au centre est et
urbanisé sur les côtés donc très peu de
prairies donc ils ont dû élever leurs
bovins de façon
avec des aliments ménagers on va dire
avec des céréales avec tous les
ingrédients du riz et donc c'est
compliqué donc pour pouvoir valoriser
leurs bovins ils sont obligés d'être
très précis dans leurs gestes dans la
découpe et nous notre animal est aussi
compliqué parce que on a comme je le
disais tout à l'heure on n'a jamais en
france penser à la viande quand on a
créé enfin quand on a développé notre
élevage bovin est par exemple le boeuf
n'existe pas en france on ne consomme
que la vache là oui c'est vrai qu'avec 4
boucherie c'est ça oui 4 boucherie
citoyens et combien de personnes on doit
être une 35 dans l'entreprise et un
restaurant où on ne cuisine que de la
viande oui oui vous inscrire la mort
d'annick voilà bon y en a on a un petit
corner dans un lafayette gourmet la vie
est on est on y sert à côté un monde un
petit steakhouse ont fait déguster ce
qu'on appelle non à points de
dégustation mais vous vous vous aimez
cuisiner ou pas moi j'adore cuisiner
alors à la maison moi je cuisine à
viande et m'accompagne cuisine les
légumes et le poisson à vous êtes
complémentaires voilà on est très
complémentaires dans votre domaine bah
je vois la viande c'est mon domaine
c'est moi qui m'en occupe et des viandes
en sauce vous quels sont vos plats
favoris
mon plat favori c'est la blanquette de
veau si quand je suis malheureux faut me
faire une blanquette et je suis heureux
ça va lancer un plat un peu has been
maintenant au moins un an non ça peut
être formidable mais c'est très beau
mais c'est maintenant des blanquettes on
en voit moins dans les récents mais
c'est rarement bien faire ah bon les
secrets d'une bonne blanquette à part la
viande c'est doit pas mettre de crème
fraîche déjà ça devait faire un bruit
bien bien fait d'apporter un petit peu
d'être d'acidulé avec le citron de bien
choisir ses morceaux de viande
quand vous avez ouvert votre premier
boucherie votre première boucherie à
asnières banlieue parisienne est ce que
vous êtes dit un jour une star vous
aviez déjà cette idée comment vous
l'avez ça s'est fait comme ancêtre avait
ouvert mardi starisation cette façon d
un gant storytelling de la viande
comment ça vous est venue bas j'étais un
enfant j'avais 18 ans quand j'ai ouvert
ma première boucherie j'étais
extrêmement naïve j'avais appelé ma
boucherie le couteau d'argent c'est un
prêt c'est un nom qui est naïf qui est
charmant un cas moi j'en suis très fier
mais qui est très naïf et j'ai voulu
tout de suite il faut savoir que c'était
dans les années 80 parce que j'ai plus
de 50 ans maintenant et c'est l'époque
87 88 où on était en pleine époque de la
viande industrielle
de des boucheries discount c'était très
compliqué donc au gt1 espèces de 2
d'original de
la viande haut de gamme de vouloir
fermer jouer je voulais vraiment avoir
la meilleure viande possible mais bien
je voulais qu'on vienne chez moi d'abord
j'étais très très mal placée dans un
endroit où où les gens venaient pas donc
pour qu'ils viennent chez moi il fallait
que j'aille la meilleure viande du monde
alors on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable c'est le quiz
alors star vous même on n'a pas de le
dire de la boucherie vous connaissez
sans doute une autre boucherie culte la
boucherie sans eau que brigitte
connaîtra bien avec son petit boucher
moustachu imaginé par hergé dans les
aventures de tintin dans quel album eh
bien il fait sa première apparition ce
boucher de la boucherie sanzot à le
spectre d'ottokar b la sphère tournesol
c'est le crabe aux pinces d'or et des on
a marché sur la lune
alors je réponds c'est moi ou bijoux de
la castafiore au début alors là il ya
des profs
et des pioches bellaïd et dans les
quatre cités dit le sceptre d'ottokar
non la sphère tournesol il y est fait
mention dans la sphère tournesol pour la
première fois dès le début de l'album
une case 3 donc dès le début du livre
voilà et ensuite effectivement ce sera
un running gag la boucherie sanzot alors
n'arrêtait pouvoir vous rattraper avec
ce deuxième crise vous le roi du steak
mature et savez vous dans quel pays on
se régale d'un steak d'ours à la russie
b la slovénie c'est le japon et des
l'espagne alors je dirais la slovénie et
je me trompe encore
japon
commencent à proposer en finlande moi
c'est penser j'ai pensé là on va
peut-être mais en tous les cas c'est une
recette culte à al qaïda au japon sa
consommation reste confidentiel harry et
il a un goût à la fois brigitte de boeuf
et de canards allons savoir pourquoi
mais peut-être qu'en slovénie mais
peut-être qu'il est protégé en survie
parce qu'en slovénie il ya effectivement
des ours c'était un peu le piège de
sauver ce quiz et vous êtes tombé dedans
braderait voilà la viande nature et
c'est votre spécialité pour pour jeudi
est revenue alors cependant qu'il ya une
grosse demande en fait les gens alors
ici beaucoup ça en france jeu comme je
ne sais pas moi qui l'aï inventé le
pourquoi je me suis mis à la maturation
je me suis mis à très très longtemps
c'était il ya 25 ans va au début des
années 90 en fait très rapidement je me
suis aperçu que j'arrivais à faire à
produire un boeuf de très bonne qualité
est pour et pour valider la qualité de
mon beauf il fallait qu'ils se tiennent
très longtemps parce que plus vous fait
mature et plus le goût de la viande se
développe et devient plus doux alors
papa for obama est au contraire plus
doux si l'élevage est de très bonne
qualité c'est comme un jambon cru vous
savez plus il est affiné et plus il a
des goûts sucrés à la fin voyez les
jambon espagnol qui peuvent vous qui
quelquefois de
d'affinage eh bien nous on obtient sa
avec le boeuf donc ça valide la qualité
de mon élevage et je me disais que si
j'y arrive eh bien personne ne pourrait
tricher ou me copier parce qu'il fallait
il faut qu'ils aient aussi l'élevage et
je vois aujourd'hui des maturation
quelquefois un peu folklorique parce que
c'est devenu un produit à la mode oui la
25 ans je faisais sans me dire on
prenait pour un fou et aujourd'hui tout
le monde tout le monde le fait et je
vois quelques fois des maturation qui
sont très oxydé très récemment en fait
on se dit tiens la viande elle et elle
est avariée quoi elle est trop vieille à
l'est alors ça y est un petit miracle
quand l'élevage a été bien fait quand
l'animal à manger toujours des choses
bien scène parfaitement saine bien
équilibré la viande est éternel on
pourrait le mature et un morceau de
viande cinq ans si on voulait ça
resterait consommables oui oui c'est
éternel parce que d'ailleurs c'est ce
que me dit voilà toxiques ancien boucher
arrive travailler chez moi qui la
connaît pas les dates de péremption là
pour la ville en mai quand l'animal a
bien élevée alors il faut que ce soit un
animal adultes c'est très important il
faut pas que ce soit ce qu'on entre
guillemets un jeune animal comme un veau
comme un agneau com ou comme certains
cochon il faut vraiment que l'animal
soit adulte et je j'ai souvent des
collaborateurs bush et qui arrivent dans
l'entreprise par ce qui arrive et
d'autres entreprises qui viennent
travailler chez moi ils sont tous
stupéfaits de voir que finalement la
viande se perd jamais il suffit de faire
un petit barrage et le dessous est
encore parfait mais tout ça c'est parce
que on est ultra vigilant de avec notre
éleveur on est ultra violent de ce qu'on
va donner à manger en fait attention ne
jamais donner de l'aide d'aliments oxydé
jamais de d'aliments tôt qu'avec de la
toxine on fait très attention à ça et
est-ce qu'on peut s'amuser nous avec
brigitte affaires maturi notre vie dans
notre réfrigérateur c'est possible
mais est ce que c'est parce que c'est
vraiment un exercice uniquement réservé
aux bouchers professionnels qui savent
maîtriser la nature en connaissez les
verts si vous savez exactement ce qu'a
mangé son animal si l'animal est adulte
s'il a un taux de gras qui est
convenable si vous avez s'il a eu un
abattage parfait s'il a une découpe donc
on amène beaucoup de sites beaucoup il
imite et puis faut quand même avoir une
chambre froide avec une décrue des prix
toute la wii ça suffit
alors en france vous savez que le repas
occupent une large place essais souvent
autour d'un bon plat que se nouent et
bien les meilleures histoires alors
c'est la brève de comptoir
alors avec marie le bourdonnec on vous a
demandé de réfléchir à une histoire
autour d'un repas est ce qu on a une qui
vous est revenu j'en avais 1001 j'en
avais mis la pâtée mais la plus
extraordinaire que j'ai pu vivre c'est
un dîner auquel j'ai participé en tant
que maître tranche heures à la villa
médicis dans la nuit alors que je me
souviens que c'est du 5 au 6 septembre
2000 nafa en fait à cette époque là
j'avais rencontré un jeune homme qui
s'appelle emmanuel giraud qui était
pensionnaire à la villa vous savez
connaissez la villa médecis à rome qui
accueille des artistes français et de
tout le monde de l'art et il ya une ya
les arts culinaires et donc emmanuel
était était dans les arts culinaires et
avait comme projet artistique parce
qu'ils ont tous un projet artistique qui
doivent mener à bien deux de faire une
relecture du festin de trimalchion c'est
un célèbre festin de la littérature du
satyricon de pétrone je fais très
intelligent disant ça mais je ne le
connaissais pas avant
l'histoire veut c'est que c'est un
esclave qui était affranchis et qui
devient organisateur d'orgies romaine et
et il est célèbre pour ses pour ces
festins couru par par deux tours homme
et son ultime festa le festin de climat
tribales qui ont ou s'il se fait manger
la fin
et on a passé il faut l'imaginer ça dans
les jardins de la villa médicis douze
convives j'étais le maître trancheur de
ce dîner je préparais la viande servie
aux anneaux convives
douze plats jamie c'était à la fois
parfois très artistiques parfois aurejac
profil vous le dites vous vous souvenez
les plans bah oui je me souviens d'avoir
servi une tête de veau sur une huître
donc j'avais une tête de veau que je
portais comme une marionnette et je
venais trancher une lame alduy qui
venaient se poser sur y avait une mise
en scène c'était théâtrale c'était très
théâtral je me souviens d'un jeu
surgissait d'une d'une fontaine où je
préparais des moulins et et je
distribuais les volailles en fait le
tout l'europe tous les plats étaient en
trompe l'oeil les gens qu'on pensait
manger du poisson mange et de la
volaille
manger du cochon et penser mange du
cochon il manger du homard voilà tout
c'était en fait c'était une grande pièce
de théâtre extraordinaire dirai combien
de temps toute la nuit donc la n 10 on a
commencé à servir le repas à 11 heures
du soir et on manger le dessert à 7
heures du matin c'était magique c'était
c'était hélas et comme juigne du nord au
maine voilà mais quand je vous disais
tout à l'heure je revendique être un
artiste dans mon métier alors c'est pas
de la prétention c'est c'est
l'artisanat quand il est poussé dans son
très très loin devient dollars et j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour certains
artistes de notre profession je pense à
romain leboeuf à hervé sancho qui sont
des meilleurs ouvriers de france qui
sont vraiment des artistes de la découpe
et ben voila moi aussi je voulais
apporter ma touche artistique et j'ai
touché l'art du doigt ce soir là cette
nuit là cette nuit là alors aujourd'hui
pour manger de la bonne viande il faut
avoir un bon boucher ou savoir lire les
étiquettes c'est le dessous des plats
depuis le 1er mars l'étiquetage de
toutes les viandes est obligatoire 20
ans après le boeuf les restaurateurs ou
les cantines doivent afficher la
provenance de leurs volailles veau ou
port une valorisation pour nos éleveurs
et peut-être un argument pour le
consommateur encouragées à acheter de la
viande française c'est une enquête de
marion becker et d'alizés boissin
en cuisine le chef s'activent dans
quelques heures elle la cantine de ce
ministère ouvre ses portes
aux menus la volaille c'est de la dame
elle vient de
de france donc on n'a que l'appellation
d'origine france voici le type de
facture qu'on reçoit donc ici vous avez
notre fournisseur bourdy co qui est là
depuis des années vous avez les mains
ces dindes bleu blanc coeur qui est
arrivé vous avez le numéro de lot
france de marquer dans les origines est
désormais l'origine de la viande sa
fiche jusqu'au 16 voilà on arrive au
niveau de notre self et vous allez voir
que en informent nos
nos usagers avec
l'appellation donc les mains c'est
aujourd'hui francs au paprika vous avez
l'origine france nous avons aussi un
fait maison vu que c'est cuisiner chez
nous et vous avez le label bleu blanc
coeur qui est aussi nommé dessus
comme ceux ci les clients ne peuvent pas
se tromper et vous avez encore un rappel
que la volaille en plus gros et bien
française élevé en france a battu en
france depuis le 1er mars la provenance
de toutes les viandes et de tous les
produits à base de viande est indiqué
pour les plats comme pour les entrées et
ses assiettes de charcuterie et ce dans
les cantines comme dans les restaurants
oc bros est réputé pour la qualité de sa
viande les clients découvrent 7
nouvelles obligations
effectivement très important il ya des
zones géographique privilégiée ou si
c'est pas français moi je mange pas ce
que je mange le calme oui alors moi pas
forcément français parce qu'ici il a des
viandes aussi qui viennent d'allemagne
qui sont formidables donc mais en
revanche de savoir d'où elles viennent
et je sais que william hague va chercher
on connaît les éleveurs va chercher la
viande
avec ses fournisseurs failli donc ça
c'est important ici le patron est un
ancien boucher intransigeant sur la
provenance de sa viande il pratique la
traçabilité depuis de nombreuses années
car depuis la crise de la vache folle la
traçabilité et l'information du public
sont obligatoires pour la filière bovine
c'est un croisement limousines salers
français bien sûr
ça c'est une bête ya quarante neuf mois
or tu es toujours le label flore de
garonne
née et élevée dans le lot-et-garonne
enfin cantal désormais cette traçabilité
précise existe aussi pour le port ça
c'est la charcuterie laborie message est
passé une commande ce matin c'est que du
produit frais donc à la traçabilité le
numéro du lot
après les chine de porc fermier
foie de porc toujours fermiers sas et
voilà c'est traçabilité sur le cochon
comme sur le boeuf maintenant regardent
peut-être encore c'est un peu plus
précis mal dans sa vie chaque lot 6 et
les cochons sont différents donc le lot
change sont pas les mêmes bon c'est un
vrai travail
puis nous après on a un appareil là haut
on va scanner les étiquettes et tous les
produits qui sont autour de cette pièce
là vont ressortir
l'information désormais obligatoire pour
toutes les provenances aura-t-elle un
impact sur la consommation des français
aujourd'hui la france importe encore une
partie de sa consommation de viande 20%
pour le boeuf 25% pour le port et même
46% pour la volaille
il marie le bourdonnec connaître à
présent le lieu d'élevage et d'abattage
pour toutes les viandes c'est une
information décisive pour vous c'est
essentiel essentiel quand on achète de
la viande il faut savoir d'où cette d'où
elle vient et comment elle est élevée
alors
depuis longtemps ça existe sur le boeuf
mais on voyait très souvent dans les
restaurants origines y eut ce n'est pas
grand chose ça grand même dire fort
origines françaises c'est important
quand même d'aller moi je suis capable
de raconter l'histoire de l'éleveur qui
l'a élevé mois mais alors le plus
important c'est justement l'élevage et
le pontil parlement elle a été levée il
ya aussi de très très mauvaises élevage
en français donc ça c'est vraiment ça
l'information comment elle a été élevée
ouais c'est pas parce qu'elle est
française qu'il est forcément bonne
oiseaux ça s'appelle
d'abattage ça apporte quoi comme
informations aux consommateurs pas grand
chose pour le consommateur enfin
généralement les eaux il ya un tissu des
abattoirs partout en france donc c'est
souvent a battu le plus proche possible
de l'élevage ci s'est élevée en france
correctement mais oui oui le bon
l'origine c'est quand même fou de
construire 2022 bord dire quand est ce
qu'on ya une information qui a passé le
lieu de naissance vous pensez que ça
manque coupant
dans le nouvel étiquetage n'ya pas le
dire oui c'est ce serait important est
important c'est important donc truc
c'est ce que serait encore plus
important de savoir comment s'est élevé
est ce que c'est élevé en lien avec le
seul où est-ce que c'est élevé hors sol
c'est ça la force mais l'information est
par exemple dans vos boucherie vous vous
indiquer ces informations la wii vous
n'êtes pas toi nous
conte l'histoire ou le 27 vous raconter
cette histoire ça intéresse le
consommateur ils sont mais il ya 30 ans
quand j'ai débuté dans le métier
personne ne savait si on était en était
au stade de martine à la ferme personne
ne savait comment fonctionnait une ferme
aujourd'hui on doit être capable de
raconter l'histoire de notre viande
c'est très important des passeurs on
doit on a raconté l'histoire de
l'élevage pourquoi le nôtre éleveurs
élèves de cette façon pourquoi dans
cette région là et pourquoi de cette
race là et pourquoi c'est pile et les
commentent les consommateurs d'une démo
et séverine c'est oui pour ça qu'ils
viennent chez vous mon pensée pour ces
pour sa formation pour voir pour être au
courant et c'est comme on est en train
de vivre un peu ce qu'a vécu le vin à
une époque à une époque on achète du vin
sans savoir d'où ça venait comment
s'était fait il
c'est il ya très longtemps et peu
importe la qualité du vin aujourd'hui le
vous allez parler du petit vigneron à
tel endroit vous êtes d'origine
juste toi je suis fier de raconter notre
histoire de l'art d'associer faire de
mon cochon les soirs de ça veut dire que
ça va encourager les français à
consommer de la viande française ça va
aller ça va les encourager à s'informer
de ce qu'ils mangent voilà plutôt ça ils
vont en demander plus du coup parce que
si on vous écoute après les et la
question vous trouvez que c'est
insuffisant cet étiquetage et bien sûr
est ce que c'est possible de faire ce
que vous voudriez c'est à dire le cv
complet de la viande sur une étiquette
c'est complet c'est possible bourse est
tout à fait possible de toute façon
aujourd'hui tout animal est tracé d'un
bout à l'autre de la chaîne donc ces
mêmes informatique s'est alors pourquoi
en fait pas un si bas parce qu'on n'a
pas envie de le faire parce qu'on n'a
pas envie de le faire parce que ça coûte
moins cher peut-être d'acheter dans des
élevages industriels donc on va pas
jusqu'où on va pas assez loin non on va
passer la transparence façon mais là je
vais fâché beaucoup de noms mais on
mange beaucoup trop de viande et de la
très mauvaise viande il faut manger
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins baissé
de la gauche et qu'il a dit il fait un
peu contradictoire oui oui on est là la
quête et qualité passera par là tout le
monde vivra mieux les éleveurs gagne
roland ries aujourd'hui les éleveurs
viennent pas leur vie avec la leur
travail c'est pas normal vous vous dites
il faut mettre fin à l élevage
industriel oui oui oui eh bien je dis
plus que ça c'est que l'élevage
industriel est mort ça n'existera plus
ça ne pourra plus exister dans dans le
temps en france ou dans le nord kivu le
monde entier de la planète n'est pas
capable de supporter ce qu'on veut ça
prend du temps j mais il ya des jours
dans une conscience il ya des prises
devrait sortie de conscience mais
pourquoi vous dites qu'il est mort enfin
en quoi aimer élevé des bovins en fit
lot aux états unis élevé des cochons en
bretagne est pollué la nappe phréatique
tout ça ça n'a plus aucun sens saleh et
puis c'est les consommateurs aujourd'hui
deux sont de plus en plus informés c'est
pour ça que c'est important cet
étiquetage et les consommateurs vont
exiger d'avoir un produit alors vous
j'ai la solution pour sauver la filière
oui c'est toute une filière derrière je
suis capable de sonnailles l'élevage
bovin français monsieur le futur premier
ministre je vous le dis j'ai la recette
est la recette est ultra simple wayne
hall a donné en exqi league
délire tout le monde de savoir on a le
monde bovin aujourd'hui en france est
divisée en deux parties vous avez le
troupeau allaitant et vous avez le
troupeau laitier le troupeau allaitant
c'est le troupeau à viande et le
troupeau laitier les troupeaux qui ne
produit que du lait il faut marier ces
deux troupes aujourd'hui se parlent pas
c'est le troupeau là ils ne se parlent
pas donc vous avez le troupeau allaitant
son job c'est de faire des veaux et de
et de les envoyer à l'exportation voilà
c'est tout et le troupeau laitier c'est
de faire des veaux pour faire du lait et
leveaux il est complètement
inutile et n'a aucun des deux n'a aucune
valorisation nulle part à réconcilier
ces deux défis ou voilà il faut aller
sur les croisements faut arrêter c'est
d'avoir cette obsession de la race pure
en france on a cette obsession de la
race pure dans le bovin c'est absurde on
ne fera jamais une viande de qualité
avec une seule race et pour faire de la
viande de qualité il faut métisser les
les élevages et c'est comme si on
demandait à un vigneron de faire un vin
avec un seul cépage ça existe mais c'est
une qualité qui n'entendent pas ça parce
qu'on les hait on leur a jamais expliqué
parce que notre culture ça a toujours
été d'avoir des animaux les plus lourds
possible on a favorisé des on a un
modèle agricole qui datent de la de
l'après guerre qui a jamais été changés
qui n'a toujours pas changé et existe
ayant pas oui ça existe dans le monde
entier les autres pays formant voir que
nous qui le faisons pas bien les choses
vous allez que nous qui nous vous
laissons cette distinction est loin de
chez nous aller en angleterre en écosse
où manger du local vous avez des animaux
parfaitement l'art vivant alors il ya
aussi des élevages industriels bien
entendu mais vous pouvez élever un
éleveur une bête complètement à l'air
vous avez des éleveurs qui gagnent leur
vie il n'y a aucun problème c'est le
canada c'est pareil dans le monde anglo
saxon c'est c'est parfait il ya quand
même une expérimentation en france on ne
connaissait pas non c'est un on est
totalement opposé à ça on est
complètement réglementation c'est pas
une obligation et non seulement la
culture la culture la culture on est
opposé à ça et on se confronte on a un
monde où on veut toujours se confronter
les laitiers contre les allées temps
il faut il faut que notre haine notre
bovins soit plus précoce qui soit plus
autonome dans son paysage et ça on l'a
on l'obtiendra avec des croisements ce
que je fais moi je fais pas de miracles
jeu quand je rencontre un éleveur je lui
explique qu'il faut qu'il ait une vache
locale et qu'il l'a marie avec un
taureau qui va lui apporter de la
précocité qui lui permettra d'être
autonome en nourriture qu'ils il aura
pas besoin d'aller chercher la
nourriture ailleurs pour nourrir son
animal aujourd'hui la facture
alimentaire d'un bovin pour un éleveur
c'est entre 2000 et 2500 euros s'il veut
faire une viande de qualité il vendra
jamais son animal à 2000 à 2500 euros la
politique vous écoute pour faire ce
alors tout le temps trop tard je me
souviens d'avoir rencontré sébastien le
fol dans son bureau au ministère de
l'agriculture j'avais fait une émission
là j'ai feinté dicks sur la recherche du
steak idéal il m'avait invité à venir le
voir dans son bureau je lui ai expliqué
sauf qu'on était en 2012 à quelques mois
de non on était en 2010 est excusé mois
avant la présidentielle juste avant la
présidentielle c'était trop tard mais il
disait mais est ce que vous êtes prêt à
combattre mais il n'y a rien de
compliqué dans ce que je propose rien de
compliqué c'est juste que tout le monde
se parle on espère que vous serez
entendu c'est vous qui le dites qu'il
faut manger moins de viande pour je fais
un appel aux futurs produits ministre
quoi vous faites appeler le jeu là c'est
fini
manger moins de viande peut-être pour
être en bonne santé alors est-ce une
garantie faut-il remplacer la viande
rouge par autre chose dans son
alimentation n'en parle et on met les
pieds dans le plat
et oui brésil gagner jusqu'à 10 ans
d'espérance de vie grâce à un régime
alimentaire ce n'est pas farfelu c'est
possible grâce à une alimentation riche
en nutriments ce sont les conclusions
d'une étude très sérieuse 1 publiée dans
la revue plos medicine par une équipe de
l'université de bergen en norvège
stéphanie des pierres et antoine coûta
on décortiquait pour nous ce régime dit
optimale
mangez des pommes et des lentilles c'est
le secret de la longévité selon une
étude publiée par l'université de bergen
en norvège un régime riche en fruits et
légumes en fruits à coques en céréales
complètes et en légumineuses permettrait
un individu de 20 ans de gagner 10 ans
d'espérance de vie les chercheurs ont
fait des calculs assez détaillé 200 g de
lentilles ou de fèves en plus chaque
jour ce serait deux ans de plus même si
vous n'avez plus vingt ans même si cette
portion vous paraît gigantesque
cela vaut le coup de s'y mettre
l'intérêt de l'étude c'est de montrer
qu'il ya justement cette progressivité
que ce soit d'un point de vue nombre
d'années pendant lesquelles on a un
régime plutôt optimale même si on n'a
jamais fait régime optimal mais aussi
d'un point de vue quantité donc si on
peut pas consommer de 100 grammes par
jour de légumineuses le fait de passer 2
10 g de légumineuses à 20 g de
légumineuses c'est déjà énorme en termes
de bénéfices liés à la santé donc faut
pas se décourager en fixant des
objectifs qui ne sont pas très
atteignable même des petits efforts si
on s'engage sur la durée c'est des
efforts qui compte et qui nous
permettent de prendre en main notre
santé et prévenir la maladie chronique
d'après les chercheurs norvégiens la
suppression de la viande rouge ou
transformée permettrait également de
gagner plus d'un an et demi d'espérance
de vie une affirmation à prendre avec
précaution selon ce spécialiste des
liens entre santé et alimentation
le scénario optimal de cette étude n'est
pas un scénario réaliste et justement
par rapport à la viande rouge et la
charcuterie on n'a pas encore assez de
recul pour dire que le fait de les
arrêter complètement à un effet majeur
par rapport à si on suivait juste les
recommandations nutritionnelles
française à l'international autre limite
de l'étude pour ce scientifique français
elle ne prend pas en compte des
paramètres individuels important la
consommation d'alcool de sel ou de tabac
mais elle a le mérite d'être simple à
comprendre et très pédagogique alors que
trois quarts des français ne mangent
toujours pas cinq fruits et légumes par
jour
alors ils marient que vous inspire cette
enquête vous avez le sentiment d'avoir
raté quelque chose dans votre vie alors
moi je veux je voudrais dire que je veux
bien vivre un an de 1 an et demi de
moins dans toute ma vie pour quelques
côtes de boeuf
des légumineuses 200 g de lentilles par
jour où les manger vous les avez bien
sûr quand vous rendez compte que 7 200 m
et ses 13 ans dix ans de vie 10 ans
d'espérance de vie ça se met bien manger
moins de viande en moi je mange pas
beaucoup de viande je fais très
attention alors c'est simplement parce
que j'ai je mange de la viande deux à
trois fois par semaine
voire quelquefois même moi
parce que je suis sujet au cholestérol
génétiquement j'ai beaucoup mieux c'est
un pôle environnement et puis je suis
tombé de santé finalement autant je
mange du beurre salé pas très bon pour
le cholestérol sain faut que je fasse
gaffe ouais je lui ai fait attention
donc je fais attention j'ai remplacé par
quoi là on va tu reviendras jeu des des
légumineuses ça m'arrive oui j'adore et
lentilles par exemple le poisson j'adore
le poisson
pas tellement question de poissons cette
enquête d'ailleurs nontron alors le web
de moins de viande mes pensées je suis
pour toutes ces solutions de manger
moins de viande puisque je le dis depuis
tout le temps on mange trop de viande et
on pensait vraiment que c'est mauvais
pour la santé proviande oui mais bien
entendu mais bien aimé ce qu'on mange
quand on dit qu'on mange trop de viande
on mange beaucoup de mauvaises relances
énormément de mauvaise viande des
burgers della zain toutes ces protos et
si on manger de la bonne viande se
serait pas mauvais on pensé pour la
santé convaincue mais on dit pas
pourtant que la viande rouge parce que
les rouges bonne ou pas bonne elle est
cancérigène ou elle peut être considérée
trop grande quantité ont toutes les
histoires d'abus si on oui c'est ça
c'est une quantité si on abuse forcément
je pense que si on mange que des
lentilles on vivra pas mieux non plus on
a eu un grand débat sur les nitrites ici
à l'assemblée nationale pour les
interdire c'est pas encore c'est pas
encore fait vous vous pensez que c'est
mauvais effectivement dangereux pour la
santé c'est ce qui permet de donner par
exemple sa couleur rose au jambon oui
bah oui ça c'est les années 70 5 80 où
on voulait des aliments qui est des
couleurs comme ça complètement naturel
clash rit donc non là on voit
xaintrailles que où je suis très
attentif la charcuterie sans nitrites on
fait très attention à ça on a un jambon
nous dans nos boucherie qui est sans
nitrites fric est pas la leur qui est
pâle oui forcément flashy il est plutôt
rose et blanc on va dire d'ailleurs
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle le jambon
blanc on l'appelle pas le jambon il ya m
c'est compliqué parce qu on dit que
les nitrites se vendent qui permet de
donner cette couleur au protège aussi
oui c'est à dire qu'on veut aujourd'hui
des aliments soit éternelle fadettes et
dure très longtemps donc oui forcément
le jambon nous il faut qu'il soit se met
rapidement sous 2 3 jours c'est ce qu'on
dit à nos clients quand vous achetez une
tranche de jambon c'est pas pour dans
trois jours c'est pour la manger ce soir
ou demain vous vous dites qu'il faut
manger moins de viande donc être
flexitariens quand vous êtes face à va 1
dvd ghana des végétariens ça vous ça
vous interpelle ça vous choque non ça ne
choque pas cru une fois plus il y en
aura et moi on mangera de vianne
plusieurs à 10 ans pour les autres non
non ça ça me gêne pas alors après c'est
pas grand enfin je trouve qu'ils ont
fait beaucoup de bruit par exemple pour
les vegan pour deux pour semble assez de
la population cela devient de plus en
plus importantes comme cette population
il faut le dire oui alors mais tant
mieux qu'elle existe de toute façon on
en mange trop donc ça nous permettra de
réguler et bien entendu il faut que ça
il faut que ça existe et ses radis alors
donc ces radicaux qui veulent s'attaquer
aux boucheries vous avez jamais été
attaqué avec sa mère vit à oui pourquoi
moi parce que je suis quand même le seul
boucher en france qui dit qu'il faut
manger moins de viande et qu'il faut des
animaux heureux pourquoi on vient les
attaques et moi on rend paru il ya bien
d'autres acteurs de cette radicalité ça
vous fait peur tout ce qui est radicale
me fait peur et ont pas beaucoup de la
culture français de la culture de
l'élevage vous imagineriez à l'elysée
par exemple un repas avec des grands
dirigeants de ce monde on ne servirait
pas de viande non elle vous choquerait
je suis en bas oui ça doit le repas
servi à l'elysée doit représenter le
l'agriculture française bien sûr je
pense comme ça existera donc il faut pas
toujours servir moins de vie en herbe
mais il ya des circonstances où il faut
soutenir et montrer qu'on soutient
envoyée
alors on passe à présent au dessert et
c'est le péché mignon
alors le temps du dessert avec un
paris-brest un totem de la pâtisserie
française petite histoire c'est que
c'est l'organisateur de la course de
vélo paris brest 1 qui aurait demandé à
un pâtissier de maisons-laffitte près de
paris de créer un gâteau pour célébrer
cette course et bien sûr ses coureurs à
ces forçats de la route le pâtissier l'a
donc imaginer n'a pas été très créatifs
mais en forme de roue de vélo voilà donc
rond plus tard on a vu apparaître des
créations carré rectangulaire
voilà et comme des éclairs effectivement
toujours de la pâte à choux plus être
crème ou au pralin mais sans la forme
originelle alors est ce que c'est un
sacrilège un paris-brest carrés où vous
en fichez alors là vous avez un rond
elle voulait que des ronds franchement
je m'en fous gare et guy novès mais met
de la crème dessus c'est
incroyable j'ai pas compris voilà c'est
pas la recette les infos officielles et
celles de ses forces ils ont peut être
voulu bien faire voilà mais c'est vrai
que dans la hausse est éloquent même il
est peut-être bon
pour le cholestérol c'est pas forcément
bien une crème anglaise en plus il est
bon
les bains la crème anglaise est vraiment
de trop un hommage à la bretagne aussi
alors oui c'est un goût de mon enfance
était le gâteau qu'on allait acheter le
dimanche midi
c'est quand je suis monté à paris
j'avais 15 16 ans chez mon premier
patron je l'avais dit que j'adorais le
paris brest et tous les dimanches il
m'apportait obtient un paris brest pour
le déjeuner du dimanche bah c'est mon
gâteau préféré je suis pas sucré du tout
ah oui c'est pas c'est pas ma passion de
sucre et j'ai le paris-brest regarder
l'autre voilà avoir ici n'ont surtout
pas un bref voyage et pas d'autres
dessert favori vous aimez cuisiner je
suis incapable de le faire bata shoe
vous n'êtes jamais jamais on m'a dit
quand vous attaquez à la pâtisserie
c'est une boucherie
savez ce que je dis quelquefois alors ça
ça va faire hurler certaines personnes
jeudi que la pâtisserie est un art
mineur
s'est passé en bas ce qui ne plaît pas à
pas c'est vraiment des artistes j'en
vois déjà quelques heures on vous dit
avec votre des couples à vous la ramenez
mais vraiment les pâtissiers aujourd'hui
c'est des artistes je vous dire pourquoi
je dis ça parce que c'est un métier où
on doit connaître toutes les doses il
faut partir d'un set et la suivre au de
j m c'est de la chimie c'est un art
mineur nous on est toujours dans la
création on est dans l'improvisation
permanente
on travaille la matière vivante donc on
est dans un art majeur
alors vous savez que nous sommes en
pleine campagne présidentielle
oui et donc nous avons pour vous un coup
et présidentielle
après l'heure ce n'est plus leur dit-on
dans les campagnes quel est le président
qui exigeaient à l'elysée de déjeuner
attention à 13 heures 10 pétantes et de
dîner à 20h 15 pétantes alors est-ce que
c'est georges pompidou réponse a est ce
que c'est valéry giscard d'estaing
réponse b est ce que c'est le général de
gaulle réponse c ou est-ce que c'est
nicolas sarkozy
il faut être sacrément rigide pour avoir
cette
voie georges pompidou
être comme ça je les y très entre
sarkozy et et le général de gaulle alors
faut pas hésiter voulant se lirait le
président sarkozy énoncé général de
gaulle le tag 13 à 20 ans ça rigole pas
alors vous savez quand termine toujours
cette émission en musique vous en avez
choisi une on écoute ensemble
progi
de
l'ennemi
[Musique]
où
de m
parce que vous fait écouter à vos vaches
à vous nina simone j'adore la simone
elle m'accompagne tous les matins on a
un métier on se lève très tôt le matin
on songe à ces agréments travail je vous
l'avais à 4 heures tous les matins je
suis à 5 heures au travail dans le
silence de la boucherie jeu mais nina
simone je suis seul avec elle elle
chante avec deux longueurs des oreilles
je comprends rien de ce qu'elle me dit
mais je suis charmé je suis apaisé je
suis heureux et et
et j'adore nina simone et vous découpez
comme ça très tôt avec le matin avant le
fracas de la ville qui se réveille après
une à simone à 4 heures du matin exfo
merci marie le bourdonnec heures
ce moment avec nous merci à jean pierre
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
merci également à chez françoise qui
nous a fourni seconde et sert est à vous
pour ce steak au point que l'on peut
retrouver bien sûr dans toutes les
bouches reid yves marie le bourdonnec
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
lcp
[Musique]